let's take some questions really good
questions this week first one is from
Sophia Sophia says if you had to kill
someone how would you do it now when i
first read the question i started
thinking how would you dispose of the
body but that's really kind of a
different question and the reason i had
the same impression yeah and the the
image we have here is from the breaking
bad TV series and might when i was
thinking how would you dispose of the
body this thing that happens a couple
times during the the series which is
they dissolve the body in acid was
something that came to mind but that's
something we can discuss but really the
question is how would we actually kill
someone and listen I'm not someone who
in any way glorifies violence or has any
desire to ever kill anyone so for me I
think it would have to be the way that's
the most disconnected from the actual
physical act of killing as possible so
like certainly gun over stabbing someone
cuz you could be further away but even
that I mean I think for me it would be
way easier to uh I don't know slipped
poison into someone's food and then not
be anywhere nearby when they're going to
die or whatever the case may be although
i think maybe part of the question is
how would you do it in a way that
wouldn't get you caught and that's a
sort of totally different set of
considerations right there there's a
very important caveat here which was
we're not actually going to do any of
this yeah but um that I think of this as
a way of how you gonna get away with it
and for me I would go with strangulation
i think it's it's a little bit
disconnected but also just not messy at
all strangulation is disconnected you
have to physically block the airway onto
someone's body until they die in your
hands I how I honor this strangulation
disconnected baby so by saying it's
disconnected but it's not messy at all
and I'm not bleeding out round you know
I guess it is pretty involved though now
I don't know with strangulation it's
very dark here today um I don't know
what strangulation if you end up like
can you get uh fingerprints off of
someone's neck if you've strangled them
so I gotta wear gloves you wear gloves
yeah I don't think strangulation would
be very low on my list very very low um
you are right though by saying that if
you shoot someone you feel disconnected
from the act relative to stabbing for
sure definitely I mean you've gotta be
unless you're an expert knife thrower
then you're gonna need to be pretty
close to someone to stab them so i think
that there's another aspect of this that
were not sort of thinking about which is
uh what about something like carbon
monoxide poisoning and you know you have
this idea of if you could just get
someone if you tie someone up in a car
in the garage and close the garage or
something like that then you could be
you could be across the country are
halfway across the country guess if you
go right to a plane and have tsa
PreCheck so you have to get there super
early to get through the security lines
uh maybe something like that and then
that that also although the person
probably wouldn't tie themselves to the
car but said but some aspect of that
might might look uh less more like a
suicide although in a suicide you
wouldn't tie yourself to the car I know
there's another angle uh i mean i would
say that by doing it in the car you
already are in a means to transport them
quickly enough and i think it may be
even more interesting part of this is
how to dispose of the body cuz yeah
that's where you're gonna get caught is
by doing that improperly yep and you
know i think that some of the things
people think about listen but by the way
this is not something i think about a
lot but we're just indulging Sophia's
question here so please don't judge us I
think some of the instincts people have
to try to bury a body it's not good
people rarely bury the body deep enough
I think just throwing the body into a
body of water is a bad idea because uh
you know if it's an ocean they could
wash ashore if it's a river the river
could be dragged same thing with a lake
type of thing so I don't know that those
are good ideas I go back to breaking bad
in the idea of dissolving the body yeah
I mean I we live near a rocky coast in
in Boston yeah and lobsters will eat
anything okay maybe I don't have to go
any further than that but if you're just
able to tie the body down if you uh you
know some shallow area of water that
body will be gone a couple hours hats
level of confidence with some of these
suggestions is scaring me and I think
it's get scaring our intern melody as
well she's like a 45 feet from pat and
she looks absolutely horrified by this
uh why are you so confident with some of
these opinions Pat maybe no comment on
this one okay so listen um I don't want
to kill anybody that's the reality of it
and I don't want to have to figure out
how to dispose the body that that's
where I come down
on this but Sofia clearly wanted
commentary on it and she got it there
are books about this if you want to be
into it sure if I'm not that you've ever
seen any of them could name any of the
main five or ten authors that right
about this stuff